stell dir vor du bekommst du eine spitze
wird sich dann zeigen dafür oder nicht
es ist eine schwierige frage hallo ich
berlin freunde herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge hero zusammen mit
komme der schritt allerdings nicht mit
sondern der ist nun der skype kommt
christmas kraft zusammen aufgenommen
haben war ich einfach nur potter ich bin
gar nicht da am besten ich putze nur so
ein bisschen und gibt es manchmal den
kommentar ab coly kannst du auch besser
wir haben so schöne wege sind sogar noch
diese platten eingefügt worden von von
cadooz oder von zombie glaube ich wenn
wir bald unsere königswall und das
wollte ich in dieser folge auch machen
und 20
könig wählen meldet ihr irgendwann sonne
ich habe mir hier übrigens nie haben so
viele leute geschrieben dass dieses haus
so unfassbar geil aussieht von mir dass
ich so bauen könnte aber naja
hier ist es die wahlkabine jetzt ist
wegen was doch ganz gut dass ich das
ganze hier nicht jetzt irgendwie weil
sie nicht anders kopf ich habe gar
keinen stich darf doch gar nicht
reingucken glaube ich was ist denn ich
darf dann gar nicht reingucken stimmen
darf noch gar nicht blöd man die
druckereien aber ja ich aber nichts
gesehen
ich musste 3 jedenfalls zettel reinlegen
wenn du im wahllokal arbeiten richter
zur wahl stehen wahl geheim nicht zur
wahl standen nicht zur wahl stehen wie
das ensemble anleitung papier nehmen
wählen nehmen freunde beschrieben
jetzt da rein dann wären wir ein wenig
denn man kann sich wohl auch nicht
selber wählen also jedoch und zombie
darf man nicht wählen ich weiß wen ich
wähle das pack lass mich raten den
manuell es in eine kiste so ich hab ich
das richtig gemacht aber ich denke mal
schon jetzt auf jeden fall cool dass wir
so eine kabine jetzt habe ich erst mal
eine ganz kleine runde kennen und
während ich in mein haus walter bauer
kommen könnten wir theoretisch immer ein
münchen reha ich habe so ganz tolle
projektidee in der box hochgewachsen
trocken
tolles haus kontinuierlich total toll
wer das geschrieben man brauche ich
fühle mich ein bisschen verarscht
ich kann mal auf twitter nachfragen was
ist denn so viel geiler tel man
heutzutage gibt was die jugend
interessiert macht paul walker können
wir darüber reden
da können wir machen klar gerne als
heute leider etwas passiert ja und zwar
komme während ich hier die sachen raus
wurde kannst du das mal ganz kurz
beschreiben oder weißt du gar keine
näheren infos
also ich weiss dazu nicht etwas näher es
auf jeden fall kam es ja also erstmal um
grundlegend zu sagen was los ist er ist
leider paul walker gestorben
und das ganze beim autounfall was aber
wir dadurch also ob er zu schnell
gefahren ist ob etwas mit dem auto war
oder so das weiß ich nicht ganz genau
ich weiß nur dass das auto ausgebrannt
ist
er hat dabei gestorben ist was ich
wirklich ziemlich schade finde
weil ich hab' ich kann dir jetzt nicht
alle teile von fast & furious ich kannte
den letzten aber und bin ich habe alle
teile geguckt und der rechte super
schauspiel und perfekt für die rolle
eigentlich ja ja und das ist wirklich
schade jetzt dass man so leute durch
solche autounfälle außen leben halt
verliert und auch gerade so natürlich
bei den film ich weiß nicht ob die jetzt
schon den nächsten teil gedreht haben
uns schon dabei waren musste mir
vorstelle was da jetzt auch für eine
stimmung herrscht einmal natürlich weil
er verstorben ist und auf der anderen
seite natürlich auch weil der film
dadurch natürlich jetzt mega noch mal
nach hinten gezogen werden muss man
einfach sagen vor allem es gibt auch
schon facebook seiten also es war halt
solche fällt heute morgen mein handy an
gemacht schreibt dann halt so gesehen
von walkers tot und es gibt sogar videos
davon war dass leute gefilmt haben wir
halt in dem auto da war wie das auto auf
jeden fall war dann halt explodiert ist
nein
doch das gibt es nein ehrlich sieht auf
jeden fall heftig aus und erstmal ip und
so was alles hier was gibt also ich
meine wir haben jetzt nicht die trauer
dir zum beispiel leute haben jetzt den
kannten weil wir sind hier ganz einfach
wir danken gott von schülern
der schauspieler traurig aber jetzt
nicht so dass jetzt deswegen jetzt die
ganzen tag kaputt machen natürlich klar
aber es ist auf jeden fall traurig weil
er halt echt super diese rolle
reingepasst hat und alles möglich und
ich weiß ich es halt irgendwie gepasst
so fest in piräus mit paul walker das
musste irgendwie wahr sein
und ja da ist die wahl kommt überhaupt
weiter viel wichtigere frage für mich
hier gerade ich wollte jedoch seine
tollen raum rand zimmern so eine art
garage für meine tiere sofort alles aber
ich kenne das der theoretisch wieder
freut mich dass hier überhaupt
da soll er noch so bittet ab und schon
mal einmal nach wie viele tote hatte 66
ort ich dachte ich habe weniger als du
ich hab leider schon sieben
wir konnten doch jede zweite folge
gestorben
da silva 10 15 toten die bei mir ist
aber auch so ich leide jetzt auch nicht
jeden tag immer hoch ich leite auch hier
auch manchmal nicht hoch wenn ich alle
halt doch trotzdem nie wenn ich nicht
gestorben wenn klar sein dass bei mir da
trotzdem kein jura kommt verweise nicht
ich dann eben kein feind apparat war so
ich denke ich war jetzt hier meinen
allerdings dran
also du kannst auch paula katholische
filme oder also ich kannte ihn ja privat
auf jeden fall darüber sollte man doch
eigentlich keine witze machen
ich weiß ich meine wir wollen selbst
nicht die ganze aufnahme dadurch kaputt
machen
ich habe auch gerade schon mal auf
twitter nach anderen themen noch mal
gefragt was da sonst noch so gibt zum
beispiel der band hat geschrieben die
globale erwärmung
wie wäre es mit der entwicklung von
minecraft so von der beta 21.7 du das
ist ein thema ist weitläufig ne das ist
einmal eine weitläufig anderer 1000
verschiedene meinungen
andererseits erkennt man schon sicher
die meinung es gibt immer diese zwei
meinungen ein crm-system ein kräftiger
geworden
den ganzen dungeons und so was alles ich
bin eigentlich damals war ich auf der
seite ja das wird alles doof aber
mittlerweile bin ich auf der seite ja
dass der eigentlich ganz cool weil halt
wirklich immer mehr geile neue sachen
dazu kommen und so was alles das ist auf
jeden fall ich weiß nicht ich mag ja und
meine meinung das so ist auch wenn man
merkt irgendwie dass ein spiel nicht
mehr wirklich weiterentwickelt wird
obwohl es noch irgendwie mein ding bugs
hat fehler hat irgendwo im
system dann macht das einfach gar nicht
mehr so viel spaß dass weiter zu spielen
war damals bei terraria so terraria
waren spiel das eigentlich auch richtig
gut an kamen aber bei der entwickler
aufgehört hat mit dem entwickeln an dem
spiel haben richtig viele plötzlich
einfach so nur deswegen aufgehört zu
spielen weil die halt wussten okay da
ist nicht mehr wirklich ein support
hinter es wird nicht weiterentwickelt
und es ist halt wirklich eine coole
sache was minecraft da liefert immer was
neues für die spieler gerade für die die
halt gerne auch nur vanilla spielen
nicht mal unbedingt für poppea so oder
hexe oder ähnlich anderem spex genau von
dem motto pack entwicklung aber genau
das macht minecraft ja unglaublich große
modding szene dies glaube ich ich würde
mal sagen in keinem anderen spiel
eigentlich so heftig gibt oder mir auf
keinen fall jeder der irgendeine
modifikation und seinem spiel drin
jeder ob die feine zertifikat auf die
weisse kleinigkeiten hat auch wirklich
jeder zweite trainiert das bekommt man
ja auch einfach einmal muss ich mir und
instagram mittlerweile runterladen und
den ausführen und schon hat man auch
tief ein
so also ich finde mein haus jetzt an
sich erst mal schon ganz schön zu dieser
gang hier reihenweise nicht das zulasse
ich mache jetzt mal noch ein paar
fenster rein das meinten wirklich so
viele blockaden haus das sieht doch
schön autokrise blabla aber irgendwie
wollten sich also denn je das meint das
ist zwar schön aber ich kann mir das gar
nicht vorstellen ich finde das nicht
ich finde das einfach nur doof findet
einfach so dahin geklatsche geschissen
hingegen hat mir gezeigt wie im real
life aus schießt euch gemacht man das
gesicht das hat einfach getroffen diese
formen vom gesetzlich richtig schön was
wie soll ich meinen dach machen wie
sollst du einfach machen ich weiß gar
nicht genau wie dein haus aussieht also
außer hasbergen die nur aus holz gebaut
hast das aus sandstein gebaut hast du
das aus marvel gebäude aus redwood
bisher edward ach so ja dann würde ich
dann dach voll scheint irgendwie auch
raus zu red wird mit dieser nähe ich hab
schon was besseres kommen aber danke für
deine hilfe der lehrer ist glaub ich
glaube dass sie besser aus als ich das
aus den workshops machen weil ich hab
das meiste aus wörth
ich weiß noch gar nicht wie hoch das
ganze machen will auf jeden fall noch
eins darüber oder nicht doch lieber zwei
darüber er hasst du lässt mein standing
zwei geschaut nicht komplett aber ich
hab da mal reingeschaut und das fand ich
eigentlich ganz cool also die aufstände
die ich da gesehen habe waren alle kann
ich dann noch eine kiste hast du hast
geschaut
nie habe ich ja nicht deswegen
tatsächlich jetzt gefragt was passiert
ist ich kann die kita hat gewonnen ich
meine ich möchte jetzt nicht völlig
verloren aber ich glaube ich es lief es
so dass teams mit hat erstmal wirklich
lange geführt und dann zur halbzeit sage
ich mal so zur hälfte verlassen mein
standing zwei kam dann so die wände wo
dann plötzlich letzten die lkw auf die
leute die jetzt hier gar nicht wissen
was das überhaupt ist ja gerne mal was
sie da überhaupt machen
und zwar passt auf es gibt ja zwei teams
einmal team pete smith und einmal let's
play together das heißt das tier von ich
sage einfach mal den oberarm hongkong
und seoul rumpel und wer jetzt noch kein
sarrazin debitor zum zombie wird diesmal
gar nicht erreichbar
diesmal nicht ich hab eigentlich gerät
entwickelt und diese beiden teams die
spielen gegeneinander jedes team hat
auch ein wild card gewinner auf einen
zuschauer anhalt und tiefe misst spielen
gegeneinander und was spielen die gegen
danach verschiedene spieler es geht
wirklich nur von minecraft geht das über
gran turismo geht über irgendwelche
alten retro spiele und da geht's halt
wirklich darum wer hat am ende die
meisten punkte
und gerade solche sachen wie meinetwegen
das ist da diesmal gab es ein panischer
der halt immer die leute bestraft hat
aber die die leute bestraft werden das
war eine sie glaube ich weiß es genau
und ich finde halt gerade mal diese
überraschende momente die auch gerade
und auch gerade in sachen die halt noch
dazu kam die fand ich ganz nett und ich
meine ich bin wenn ich hundertprozentig
sicher dass diesmal team let's play
together gewonnen hat ich bin mir nicht
so hundertprozentig sicher ich schaue
eben noch mal nach bevor ich mich da
noch mal antue
das korrigiere ich mich aber ich glaube
wir haben gewonnen
ok ich hab' duell um die welt gekocht
mit joko gegen klaas das ist ja european
class ich feiere einfach die beiden
leute die passen einfach super zusammen
das läuft alles richtig schön also ich
weiß ich ich mochte das als ekelig habe
es auch gar nicht so heftig doll
mitbekommen dass das jetzt eben noch mal
stattfindet wir haben zwar alle
hochgeladen aber ich habe dazu neben
total verdrängt in dem moment und dir
denn archive hier schreiben wenn ich was
mache ich hier wieder setzt sich mal die
ganzen scheibchen rein aber ich denke
last man standing 2 ist ja auf myvideo
noch gespeichert oder so kann man sicher
das ist noch viel speicher kann sich
auch anschauen wie man möchte ja dann
hier daraus wahrscheinlich dann noch mal
geben
ich hab das geht wirklich wie lange geht
das sechs stunden summen trainer ja ja
auf jeden fall wichtig lande
die mlpd hat gewonnen ja gut
peter mieth sind dann
peter h d day und die alu oder wie genau
und halt noch dabei glatt gewinnen und
kommen jetzt auch mal mitzumachen
meister aber auf jeden fall bock drauf
aber ich stehe ja noch nicht so in der
öffentlichkeit von einem gesichter und
so weist dabei schreit nein also klar
das ist bestimmt eine lustige sache
denkst du dich denn irgendwann mal zu
zeigen wenn du denn jetzt zb angebot
bekommst komme werde wasser selber
fotografiert angebot von lesben standing
nato krieg oder von prosieben du kriegst
eingekauft prosieben wirst du dich dafür
zeigen eine eigene show auf prosieben
sondern dass für eine show sein
ich weiß nicht ob mich darauf auch schon
wieder
würdest du dich dann zeigen wenn du so
eine show angeboten bekommen würdest
wollen das kommt ganz drauf an was für
eine show ist stellt dann kommst du
schon sowas samstag 20.15 wodurch die
gäste ein lied aus der gaming szene dann
quatsch ich ein bisschen spielt ein
bisschen spiele
stell dir vor du bekommst du eine show
wird sich dann zeigen dafür oder nicht
es ist eine schwierige frage
wenn das angebot so ein bisschen stimmt
und ich wirklich weiß ja dass ja das ist
echt schwierig machen oder dich es ist
ein einmaliges ding war wirklich eine
show die langläufer ist also so wie
meine links und stefan raab dann da
würde ich dann wahrscheinlich schon die
sichtweise ändern und vielleicht also
schon mal in einer viel höheren
wahrscheinlichkeit mich zeigen ich kann
aber auch nicht jetzt ja sagen wenn das
mich plötzlich frei sein sollte dann
kommt anfrage
heute abend oder so wird der anfall beim
hereinkommen eine sternschnuppe oder
meteorit beides geht aber auch die
diskussion ist eine stern stoff
verfallen
aber erstmal zum thema also ich weiß es
nicht ehrlich gesagt genau also ich
schwierige sache ist weil ich meine hat
man auch automatisch weniger zeit denke
ich mal wenn man das so eine show hat er
ja aber dadurch wird er unser geld
verdienen durch so was wie viel wie viel
verdient man sagen kann die hot rods ich
weiß halt nicht ob das momentan für mich
das richtige ist wenn ich so eine show
machen will da war ich werde ihn gar
nicht mal so abgeneigt also bock habe
ich auf jeden fall drauf hätte auch bock
auf zum beispiel gamescom wir sind eine
eigene bühne oder so wo ich so wie
letztes jahr das was krank gemacht hat
das war so geil fand ich das mal wo alle
abgegangen sind mit krank und sarrazin
traumbilder 20 mega geil da die ganze
aktion war auch dabei wie neda war ich
nicht dabei ich habe mir das angeschaut
habe ich mega bock drauf bekommen
fertigparkett hier das ist für mich die
ganze zeit beim bauen
aber ich denke ansicht ich mein haus auf
jeden fall richtig geiler sind jetzt
zwar schon gleich wieder am ende der
folge aber ein bisschen gequatscht die
abgabe sich zeigen würde wenn er denn
angebote also prosieben ende des gerade
gut gemacht doch mein angebot mit einer
million euro pro sendung der zeigt sich
natürlich wichtig würde ich glaube ich
würde mir auf jeden fall zeigen weil
sowas
ich hätte auch richtig bock auf seine
show natürlich schon dass es sehr
unwahrscheinlich da würde ich mich
wahrscheinlich auch so zeigen nein
gesagt so ich würde mich high heels
tisches bord ist auch müßig richtig weg
jetzt noch eben die plantage plantage
die dachten wir hier so mehr oder
weniger dran
mein problem ist es immer wenn ich mich
mit kleinigkeiten beim hausbau mal so
stark beschäftigen irgendwie eine treppe
und mit irgend einer treppenstufe davon
beschäftigt nämlich beschäftige ich mich
einfach stunden so in etwa also gefühlte
stunden und in wirklichkeit sind das
fünf minuten was er schon lange dauert
weil ich dann will wen ich habe nämlich
jetzt das holz oder anderes oder doch
nochmal abreise aus dass katja was ich
gerade mache ich mache mein hausdach und
ich habe eine kiste und kisten regal
gemacht und die kisten die stehen dann
wirkt direkt unterm dach
und wer dann doch ganze ja genau die
real sie stehen direkt da direkt einen
blog darüber dass altmann dach und
welche als einen ganzen block beachwood
wurden worldwatch dingsbums welcher ein
blog direkt zu drücken würde die kids
nicht mehr öffnen
deswegen muss dieser tage drüber packen
deswegen muss jetzt ganz viel fällen
damit ich ganz viele halbe hab die
ganzen halben darüber
das sieht aber auch illegal aus und ich
denke dann mache ich mir dann noch mal
so ein cooles doch irgendwie kommen da
kann ich mich auch einladen also ich
habe die erlaubnis von zombie dass wir
da das portal von dem benutzen dürfen
ja da lade ich dich da mal ein und dann
kann ich einen tollen kaffee trinken das
finde ich natürlich geil
wir sprechen über die genauen
konditionen für prosieben jetzt weg ist
ja auch gerade im mai kraft will nicht
dass du zu positiven hilft hier fängt an
zu regnen
aber gab es nicht bei irgendeinem portal
eine falle wenn man dadurch geht dass
man die lavafelder ich glaube da wolle
man sogar in die hölle die ihr halt ist
das egal
wieso macht aber ich weiß es grad gar
nicht umfallen ich dass ich dann zu
sagen
je öfter ich komme danke dass es
bestimmt ein portal so wenn wir
natürlich in den smart forvision auftrag
gegeben wer aber auch nicht da schon
auftrag auftrags ausführende personen
hier alle willig bubi man ich möchte
mich kriegen bevor die folge zu ende
geht aber ich beiße ich hasse das so
feinarbeit
als es dort bei mir ich lange aber ich
dann verbaue ich mich so oft und dann
aber wenn ich dann so hoffen geld vor
allem mit zu kleinen blöcken arbeiteten
die wir dann ivo hinsetzen muss wieder
leer hier natürlich wieso das so sind
einmal meinetwegen die kleinigkeiten
dauern lange aber auch die wenn man
meinetwegen große flächen mit holz
fällen müsste dort auch ewigkeiten sei
aber man darf das nicht mehr rein
was haltet ihr von meinem haus schreibt
seine kommentare ich finde das irgendwie
mega cool also irgendwie mittlerweile
finde ich jetzt nimmt formen an
wir können ja noch mal hier von da oben
hier schauen oder wie komme ich denn
jetzt da wo ich da überhaupt irgendwie
hochgekommen ich finde das ist schön
dann machen wir da so ein feldchen hin
meinen kleinen garten und dann ist das
ein schönes haus auf jeden fall sowie in
der ecke kommt so ein besseres dach
drauf aber ich finde jeden fall erstmal
danke gott dass er dabei war
die danke fürs hier dabei sein ich will
ich fand's eine recht lustige folge auf
jeden fall ja
geht diese ganzen themen ich hätte jetzt
natürlich auch noch könnte jetzt noch
anderen teams schauen aber da war
richtig lustig foto von unserer
wahlkabine einer für mich stimmt ihr du
hast ja heute gewählt habe ich schon
wieder völlig vergessen
tja wenn ich jetzt noch ich würde
natürlich jetzt gerne wissen wenn du
gewählt das war mist damals in folge
anschauen wo verdammt
die folge kommt sogar heute noch online
als jetzt wisst ihr wenig gewählt habe
ich hoffe ich habe alles richtig gemacht
oder will ich erstmal sagen meine
freunde weit gefahren hat dann hat auf
jeden fall den daumen da schaut auch bei
combe vorbei der macht ihr auch hier und
da und an meiner hand schauen noch mal
bei luca vorbei höher du bist zwar
gerade drin aber schaut euch die folge
einfach normal am dienstag ist wieder
der ein bisschen was gut oder